[Musica]
doveva succedere qualcosa di eccezionale
in questo quadretto rosso in questo
cerchio rosso come vedete non succede
gli eccezionali dispiace per voi
probabilmente succeda qualcosa
eccezionale dopo il mio compito è quello
è quello di contro un po a un po il
ghiaccio e parleremo di cose strane
perché se avete il caos significa tante
cose ma non significa strettamente
niente se lasciamo anche a capire poi
siamo anche uomini bases probabilmente
la prima cosa in quale rivolge ai neo so
se lo sapete ma c'è una storia strana ma
stata una storia veramente strada
i leoni soffrono di ulcera mani dicembre
c'è un noto biologo che c'è scritto
libro molto bello sul tema ma vediamo
perchè sta succede questa cosa che si
potrebbe servire da un punto di vista
del business per capire il caos perché
migliori confusioni per capire che cosa
succede soprattutto come reagire a
questi fi 9 poi immaginate la scena di
questo povero questo leone della savana
che la mattina e glieli concentrate vide
passare un azienda c'è pranzo per la
giornata è ovviamente l'ambra tutta la
sua strategia che anche ha sperimentato
negli anni dai la bora con tinua a
guardare comincia la rincorsa ma la
zebre più forma a zero e riesce a
scappare è quel giorno il lione resta
senza mangiare torna nella sua tana e
cominci a ragionarci e dice ho fatto
questo il giorno dopo stessa c'è la
stessa scia stessa terra stesso leone
rincorrono a zero e ancora una volta la
zebra riesci a scappare
il mio ritorno a casa la zebra a nella
sua vita na testa un giorno al quarto
giornale oggi diviene lucera e alla
sembrano sapete perché annozero di vero
c'era perché capace di dimenticarsi
completamente quello che è successo e fa
una cosa fondamentale i musicisti
conosciamo molto bene che si chiama la
cadenza d'inganno ogni mercato ogni
attività che noi facciamo è fatto da
premia predatori quando lo soffriamo i
clienti al nostro competo siamo i
predatori ci sono le prede noi siamo le
prede
e la preda se fosse sempre così facile
il predatore beccherebbe la prenda
sempre quello che fa la differenza
esattamente quei musicisti che amiamo la
cadenza d'inganno tu pensi che io faccio
una cosa ma perché mi sono dimenticati
di quello di ieri
faccio una strategia completamente
diverse ti frego gli arresti senza
mangiati la cadenza d'inganno la non
linearità del pensiero se tu pensi che
questo sia la traiettoria per te e lione
resta e purtroppo resta con lui c'era
perché va sempre male
guardate un altro esempio di questo
fenomeno che mi sta che fare un leone
che anche farvi una zebra lo sapete
esiste questo teorema non so se lo
sapete si sa ma la maledizione radiati
ai maggio 1941 ai suoi per un attimo e
fatemi questa cortesia diventati
decennio della michelin 1940 arrivo io
che sono il campo della ricerca vengo da
voi che se ti ceo in un mercato
ipercompetitivo com'era all'epoca e dico
o inventata una cosa nuova
quello che si chiama appunto e
pneumatico radiale primi hanno tutti
meno mazzi lineare e io il mio capo di
voi come c'è perché c'è di nuovo
costa 20 per cento in meno una
produzione e permette di fare il doppio
dei chilometri che facciamo e ragazzi
nome la scelta questa che fate pensateci
un attimo mercato è che io mettendo
questi disco queste nuove per questi
problematici che ho una macchina faccia
il doppio dei chilometri
faccio sempre lo stesso numero dei
chilometri e devo decidere che fa ho
pensato un attimo da cielo qual è il
nostro comportamento di the pass
passiamo alla produzione o di te ma che
ci frega tanto poter fare i soldi in
questa maniera se passiamo 50 anni
dunque lui e steve jobs era un
ricercatore della coda va dal suo campo
evidentemente dice guarda che io ho
inventato la macchina fotografica
digitale ea chi li fate un attimo è
certo che de cesare di mercati se dei
leader del mercato come la vera michelin
siete leader del mercato e dovete
decidere questa cosa qua di seguito a
questa innovazione conoscete bene
la conosce benissimo la xland fra sul
mercato perché ha deciso di distruggere
qualcosa sul pensiero completamente
irrazionale completamente non lineari
l'acqua più cara il massimo del mercato
non c'è più e allora capite
ecco la cadenza di indiana è che a preda
predatore ancora una volta capite
benissimo qual è la situazione
devo decidere distruggere qualcosa per
creare un qualcos'altro
e voi non compriamo continuiamo a
comprare telefonini abbiamo smesso di
comprare telefonini perché perché non
c'è nessuna innovazione
continuiamo a comprà telefoni che
l'unica cosa che fanno è avere più
potenza e la macchina fotografica non me
ne frega assolutamente niente
qual è l'innovazione innovazione tutto
quello che vedete di metà partita
abbiamo solo i titoli ma del non c'è
assolutamente niente rivoluzione
digitale blog c'è tutto il solo dei asta
o come dice giustamente giacché nulla e
la pornografia di questa roba qua
vediamo nelle immagini è come vedere
degli spezzoni video pornografico e
pensate che vedendo 5 di una cosa potete
imitarlo e fare la stessa cosa non
funziona così ci sono ragionamenti
dietro ci vuole il coraggio di fare cose
perché altrimenti la maledizione del
radiale rim per sempre la michelin e
ancora la colla che sparita
adesso vedremo altri esempi la michelin
ha ancora una volta ha deciso di
distruggere il suo mercato presentando
un pneumatico di raffone gli animi le 23
è quella di un valore diverso costerà
praticamente niente troppo te lo potrai
costruire a casa questa innovazione il
pensiero non lineare altrimenti preda e
stati metti il predatore vi fa sempre
fuori c'è sempre una preda a un mercato
a tutti sta un cliente andare a
prendersi riscatti negli anni c'è sempre
e l'unico modo che ha è quello di
cadenza d'inganno che tu penso che chi
sta lavorando su una cosa è solo idrico
ecco invece disposti pensiero non
lineare sia abituata pinzi non lineare
alla coerenza del nostro ci coerente ma
coerenti rispetto a cosa rispetto a cosa
queste allora data cosa che vi dicono in
continuazione non reinventare la ruota e
il residenziale stupidi vostro che lui
contri amari
ed è proprio questo questa mancanza di
cadenza d'inganno che ci fa fregare
voi sapete benissimo che oggi usate
troppo tutti quanti altri sistema prima
c'era il next è oggi utilizzato in tutti
i twitter o utilizziamo la tutti twitter
ma prima c'era è sicuro prima di spotify
cena nominato cioè prima di qualcosa
c'era qualcos'altro
perché se spari di queste cose qua
perché perché sono sparito è sparito
chrome è sparito netscape a favore di
chrome e così le pertinenti questo ci
dobbiamo gr ed è semplice ragazzi basta
tornare i complimenti
il mito di atalanta e di pomenti propria
mappa scusano già spazi di noi e la
squadra di calcio è un mito greco non
poco famoso poco uscito probabilmente il
primo verrà portato all'evidenza è stato
edoardo de crescenzo l'ingegner
decrescenza e racconta questa storia
atalanta la figlia di questore di questa
di questa isola greca era femmina per
cui ci voleva un maschio e la caccia di
casa vi era la faccio breve vale niente
viene allevata lascia dai lupi diventa
una bravissima cacciate ce l'ha più
grandi corritrice diventa il più del più
del più protetta a seconda degli dei il
padre decide di farla ritornare alle 10
e diventerà regina di questa terra
se sono semplicemente di sposeranno e
lei accetta diciamo una condizione però
la condizione che voglio è che mio
marito mi deve battere alla corsa che
era impossibile lo sapete era
impossibile finché non arriva il pomini
tipo bene
innamoratissimo è innamoratissimo
scrivere le poesie delle lezioni d'amore
su di lei impressionanti e lei ramona e
tutti i costi sa che perde che rischia
di morire
sa che rischia di morire ma non si perde
d'animo ha una sua strategia si mette in
tasca tre pomidoro e durante la corsa
mentre sono appaiati lui fa cadere il
primo pomodoro
ovviamente il pomentino queste aziende
che dicevo prima sicura di sé o tutto il
mercato con me io a questo qui lo prendo
quando voglio
si ferma a raccogliere il primo polo e
ovviamente come ne comincia col n
ovviamente riesce a raggiungere a quel
punto il po meno e fa cadere il secondo
promo lei si ferma di no perché è
convinta la migliore la più forte
non c'è nessuno dietro di me dentro
bambini potrà mai battere si ferma la
seconda volta di nuovo l'aria fresca
diana per terzo uomo solo che le stava
attrezzi accorge che il traguardo e gli
indici nel raccogliersi po meno vince la
sposa
qual è la morale di questa storia c'è
una morale che quando tu pensi di essere
avanti quando pensi di essere
imbattibile guardate nocchio guarda
tutti quelli che hanno messo quando
pensi di essere in bottiglie che non c'è
nessuno che ti piacerà solo io
c'è tutta questa roba qua ti accorgi che
qualcuno dietro di ha preso le misure
ti ha preso le misure e ti sorpassa ecco
preda predatore
ecco che cosa significa la cadenza
d'inganno ecco che cosa significa per
altra cosa fondamentale è che molto
spesso quello che noi vediamo maestri
con la nostra linearità e chi sono delle
cose che sono nati per fare delle robe
ele facciamo delle altre voi tutti
conoscete immagino la la scatoletta del
tonno si merita quando tornò nella
carità che si rivela chiavetta per
aprire la scatoletta invece no l'uso
primario non so se qualcuno gianni età
si ricorderà l'uso primario la chiavetta
era aprire le macchine fiat dell'epoca
da 500 a 600 e 128 e metterli in modo
era era l'ideale per i dati una cosa che
annata delle attività che servita ad
altro guardate il gps che è nato per
mandare le persone sulla linea oggi a
quello che serve per consegnargli la
pizza a casa ma chi è che sia al posto
di questa roba qua chi ci sono molte
canzoni pop che venne utilizzata dalla
cia per tutti sono nate nel nostro
divertimento e vengono utilizzate dalla
cia per torturare per torturare i
prigionieri dai bachi si accorge di
questa nuova attuale saprete la storia
che tutti raccontano dvd di newton gara
su youtube è falso però per dare l'idea
seduto sotto la quercia che dica si usa
sotto l'albero di melo di carne lamela
in testa
immagina la gravitazione ma adesso io
richiedo la scienza che fa ma quanta
gente era caduta la mia sulla testa
inizio nera è questo il tema che abbiamo
siamo talmente presi dalla quotidianità
c'è una mente messa le nostre regole dai
nostri meccanismi delle nostre
metodologie dalle nostre attività
quotidiane che ci prendiamo tutto quello
che sa tutto e andiamo ai convegni e
parliamo di contesti dobbiamo stare
attenti al ponte non è vero siamo troppo
presi dalla st quello che si governano
gela profonda ignoranza la profonda
superficialità con cui affrontiamo i
problemi è una profonda superficialità
mio pacher delle battute gigantesche su
questo fenomeno ai file la vostra
ignoranza annuncia una lacuna ed
esattamente quello che ci confrontiamo
tutti i giorni facciamo finta di niente
lo vediamo adesso con dopo in onda
insomma certo non sappiamo che cosa fa
sappiamo che reagire la tecnologia sia
abbandonato perché pensavamo che tutto
si potesse risolvere una tecnologia e
abbiamo scoperto che non è vero che
abbiamo scoperto che non è bene e che
cosa significa tutto questo non so
quanto riguardano netti il pinocchio
esiste una regola fondamentale di tutto
questo si è sì ed è esattamente quello
che trovate scritto lì le immagini sono
di abiti di agonisti ha disegnato il
pinocchio molte volte per esempio per
dirvi la superficialità e io faccio
sempre sempre di minotti perché il più
facile dei potrei fare centinaia le
faccio piloti perché tutti al canneto
pinocchio hanno sentito parlare se
potessi chiedere in questo momento che
il mestiere faceva geppetto e non è vero
non avete letto perché l'ultima pagina
quello di scrivere legge tetto torno a
fare il suo vecchio mestiere
intarsiatore non c'entra niente famiglia
vi siete premio di spa veniamo in
continuazione di un pinocchio e quelli
di meno un g20 torino eppure basta per
il peggio perché perché ne abbiamo tempo
per approfondire e con l'odio è talmente
preciso che lo dice anche lo leggete
l'intanto geppetto tornò zoppicando non
possiamo arrivare da nessuna parte se
gli zoppi chiamo sono ma inciampare
confluente della cadenza d'inganno non
arriva
se non arriviamo da nessuna parte ci
sorpasseranno sempre lo zoppica re e
l'unica condizione per la quale noi
siamo delle persone vive zoppica zoppica
di hollis domnica se ne rendo vulcano
tutti zoppica
perché l'idea de viti antichi era non
puoi arrivare alla verità
se non tentennando se non riuscendo a
capire dove muoverti che cosa fa
jobbik a zoppicare zoppica questo il
caos che ne sapete chi è più grandi
supplicato di questo senso
[Musica]
crediti
andiamo alla grande vogliamo
milano si parte del testo sto mica in
continuazione 6 almeno in ottica non
risolve nessun caso
[Musica]
pensiamo di potere
ponte di tutti
i problemi standa se non uscire pure
allo standard
se non riusciamo ad uscire fuori da
questa condizione si alzano sempre delle
prede facilmente facilmente abbordabili
da predatore cadenza di bianchi zoppica
questa è una re ne esistono delle altre
ma questo la piccola deviazione
la piccola il piccolo far qualcosa che
gli altri non fanno non aspettava
assolutamente gli eventi e allora vi
rendete conto prima che faciliti nel
caos il caso diversità del problema di
pinocchio è semplice chi gliel'ha detto
che diventa diventando un bambino vera e
la media essere un burattino le
condizioni diversità e allora in ognuno
di voi in ognuno di noi quando vediamo
qualcosa di diverso
quando vediamo qualcuno le fa uno sforzo
per andare al di là per implementare
questa cadenza d'inganno cerchiamo di
capire qual è lo sforzo zoppicando
assieme a lui
amiamo la differenza degli altri e
quella piccola differenza che fisici e
che i teorici del caos siamo un effetto
farfalla ed è la cosa si vuole più
poetica che possa dire che si occupa di
casa la piccola differenza che fa il
grande movimento e l'effetto farfalla e
codificata una teoria del caos in questa
maniera una più battito d'ali oggi di
una farfalla a busto arsizio potrebbe
causare in tornato dal messico il
prossimo anno stiamo attenti ai dettagli
siamo attenti alle piccole alle piccole
variazioni
grazie mille
[Applauso]